nuanced understanding of relationships
to be able to say that I am happy I'm
happy on my own because it sounds an
awful lot like you don't want someone
mmm which isn't the case normally I
think from watching a special it sounds
like an uncompromising set standards on
what you will accept as a partner I it's
really it's not even that like I don't
think getting apartment they should sort
of be in if I don't have any
expectations of my future partner for me
I just think falling in love should be
the most inconvenient thing in the
[ __ ] world like it should ruin your
day like people who when they fall in
love like I know it's in love because
every time I thought about them I smiled
and I was happy I'm like no no no that's
you in love with the idea of love it's
not by the individual you didn't love
with the idea of being in love and you
love the feeling of being loved when
you're actually in love like I think
it's just you know you just go off for
[ __ ] sake I was having so much fun I
was living my best life and then this
person came along and they make me laugh
and I want to spend my time with him I
love used to love being alone I know
every every time I'm in a situation I'm
enjoying my brain goes I wish this
person was here with me I want to share
this with the [ __ ] god damn something so
much fun yeah I had so much freedom and
I still have that but just now I can't
stop it oh yeah every time I've been in
love I've just gone you bet yeah I love
you so much and that's so inconvenient
for me because I was enjoying being
selfish I was enjoying and now I love
you so much that you're my priority and
that's insanity I suppose I suppose what
huh
[Music]